As soon as I found React, it became clear
that this was the right way to do things.
What I love about react is that it's
going to set your career up for years to
come. As a front-end developer things
are constantly changing. The patterns
you'll see in React are the same
patterns current and future front-end
frameworks will utilize. Not to mention,
learning React will enable you to build
web apps, native apps, or even apps in
virtual reality. By learning React today
you're future proofing your career. I am
Tyler McGinnis; I'm from Eden, Utah.
I am a Google developer expert, and I
work full-time on TylerMcGinnis.com
The paradigms and the principles that
you learn in React are all of a sudden
becoming popular in all these other
frameworks, so by learning React, React
isn't just going to teach you a new API
it's gonna help you learn nice software
principles that you can then apply to
different frameworks and languages.
What I really like about this collaboration
is that it combines both of our
strengths. I've been teaching React in
the React ecosystem for a few years now,
so I feel like I have a pretty good
grasp on how to teach it. And what
Udacit provides that I can't are things
like code reviews, mentorship, and the
in-class experience. We think it's gonna
make you a much better developer so come join us!